all right I am a local business owner
hmm I need to buy paper I find out
everything about their prices and
policies you're a fictitious name
Michael Scarn good
I am a paper salesman looking for a new
job I find out everything about their
expenses and salaries okay then we meet
at the Denny's and we compare no no I
never said Denny's IHOP no I I said do
you know how I feel about I start don't
like socialists I don't want to get into
this debate again Kay I enjoy uh-huh
I'll have a cup of coffee you will have
pancakes and you'll like it just don't
answer that must release so what means
are not abandon we were shrinking no I
could be shrinking no because the sign
is centered perfectly above their store
no sign of the sign being moved Wow it's
lunchtime there's no sign of anyone
coming in or out which means they're not
taking new customers out to lunch Romans
are not acquiring their business so once
again no growth huh no clouds the clouds
in the sky whose gonna rain bad for
business
well what if they were altocumulus and
not cirrostratus why are you all okay
Michael whatever your clouds right stop
okay
so you're going now I'm gonna go in in
exactly 10 minutes we have never met
each other we are complete strangers
right also we're gonna need a signal to
bolt out of there in case there is
danger and that signal is lick your lips
try it no no like this
okay ready to do this yeah all right
here come the Sharks
[Laughter]
[Music]
get out that can under police tape is
this what do we get back windows broken
two sets of sneaker prints alarm went
off at 11:43 and security arrived at
11:46 perps are already gone okay I'm
thinking classic s I'm thinking old
times I'm thinking roleplay guys okay
I'm Jacques Guillaume and you are unreal
know we are cat burglars on vacation
from France I love it although Inari
went to an elite international school so
he does not speak with an accent oh my
way to flesh out the characters thank
you okay so I break the back window make
my way over the jewelry case meanwhile
you're standing lookout we're we in the
front door smoking a cigarette check it
ash okay so I am smoking ready then Oh
Jacques roses own cigarettes a habit he
picked up from a prostitute Marseille
but that is not all he picked up why do
I your characters get STDs you start
living mine all right so I go to the
first case smash steal a bunch of
watches move over to the second case
smash bracelets then we hear a sound and
I yell need condoms it's lumpy see and I
know what that means because I'm French
but asked you to repeat it in English
just to be sure police are here
yes we gotta get out of here so we turn
to leave you flick your cigarettes using
the cane he's in the cane this is
awesome
voila see but I thought on we didn't
have an accent it comes out when he gets
excited Ben what is the first rule of
the Leslie Knope emotional support task
force you don't let her get a tattoo
what the hell happened I couldn't help
but she's so cute when she's coming up
with destructive ideas
never send a husband to do a best
friend's job out Wyatt walk it off walk
it off fine
and you did it yeah later no nope sit
down oh you are avoiding your problems
what no I'm not
can we talk about this tomorrow and
we're down in the polls your opponents
were well-funded and will organize you
must have known this would be a
possibility intellectually I knew that I
might be in trouble but deep in my heart
I never really felt I tried to help you
but as usual you're the best person for
the job
I wrote this you need to hear yourself
read it they held the recall election
and I lost I was voted out of office in
30 days I will no longer be a Pawnee
city councilor oh it's so hard to read
when you're drunk keep going but I am
Leslie Knope I am more than a city
councilor I am an unstoppable force of
energy and I will use those days to work
as hard as I can
these are all your ongoing projects
everything you're currently working on
for Pawnee you have things to do you've
a month left use it man
you poetic noble and mermaid you're
right once again thank you I flush my
car keys down the toilet Toy Story
Finding Nemo up eyeball the entire time
I cannot watch Pixar Michael yes not
just one of wars
I found two minutes oh my god
twins I'm sorry you understand nice to
meet you aren't they magnificent the men
white I love finding a good set of twins
something is wrong okay Duke the cars
picking me a name you up in two minutes
you sure you're cool keeping tabs on my
cases well I'm on the cruise you bet I
hope you have a great time
hey don't make any new best friends
maybe you shouldn't go and is killing it
my campaign team is unstoppable this
rally is gonna be awesome
oh my god I'm feeling I'm gonna
breakdance hey Leslie thank God I got
gum in my hair you do this just stinks
don't touch it please don't touch it you
got a ton of dandruff okay let me be how
do you get going here I was walking in
and I noticed something shiny under
Stanley's car and I got under see what
it was and I messed up my hair all for a
stupid piece of tinfoil but best case
scenario you thought it was a corner
kill me right now we have peanut butter
in the kitchen I don't feel like peanut
butter give me an ice-cream sandwich oh
not for you it's for your hair and it is
9:00 a.m.
no Dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good tastes good too oh don't
that's disgusting a lot of calories well
just don't leave it on too long keep
massaging please oh yeah that's nice
maybe so but it's what I invented when I
was six because my mom was working so I
had to make dinner for myself my sad
story Trump's your insult Jake Jake Jake
Jake Jake Jake Jake Jake Thank You
Borden who is your doctor Ann's my
doctor and she's the most beautiful
nurse in the world what are you wearing
come on it's a casual social outfit
looks like you're going to a fish fry
Dwight don't they're howling at the moon
it's suggestive to women
because of howling during sex okay okay
come on let's go there he is
all hail the birthday boy Charles
probably shouldn't have done that in a
police station and not celebrate your
birthday properly
I'd rather get shot you do you I thought
maybe you'd want to talk more about all
the crazy stuff going on I do I really
do thanks yeah I'm just gonna tell you
I'm a little tired okay so I may have
parked on your front lawn oh you did
I did hmm Leslie and I had an amazing
talk it was so great of her to come over
here even though she was exhausted
beyond belief anyway after we talked she
fell asleep on my couch and she's been
asleep for 22 hours
it's amazing what she slept through at
one point I thought she was up : hi Hey
but then she went right back to sleep
I've been monitoring her vital signs
she's totally fine I love her so much
but I think I'm gonna draw a mustache on
her face okay who's this problem
Wow we look at that Jersey cool oh great
from Dwight thank you
right that's great thanks my hutch
my hunch my lovely Casey hunch gone Jake
sing with me that's not gonna happen
I will literally never what you gonna do
with all that hunch oh that hold you
inside your brain we're gonna solve this
case
solve this case right in your face we
should probably leave this prison yep
oh and I always wanna get because you're
so putting on Easter rejection
you